McGann is rushing hundreds of troops to
the Middle East after pro-iranian
protesters tried to storm the US embassy
compound in Baghdad soldiers from the
82nd Airborne Division boarded c-17
transport planes at Fort Bragg in North
Carolina yesterday they are headed to
Kuwait their deployment comes after two
days of violence at the UM u.s. embassy
from militias upset about deadly US air
strikes the protesters have now pulled
back from the area and images of the
aftermath show extensive damage
including a burned-out reception area on
the edge of the embassy compound Ian Lee
is in Baghdad for us this morning
Ian good morning good morning the u.s.
is beefing up its security presence in
Iraq after the embassy was attacked but
as the violence subsides many wonder
what this means for us Iraq relations
the Iranian backed protesters outside
the US Embassy may have stopped for now
they dismantled their camp and moved
across the river but what they left
behind wasn't just parts of the compound
scorched and in ruins but also us Araki
relations in tatters this recent crisis
are on flex its muscles revealing the
extent of Tehran's influence in the
country it began with the u.s. blamed
iranian-backed Shiite militias for
killing an American contractor in a
missile attack on an Iraqi base last
month the u.s. retaliated with
airstrikes on those militias bases in
Iraq and Syria killing more than two
dozen fighters that sparked 48 hours of
intense protests Iraqi security forces
stood aside when supporters of those
iranian-backed militias marched to the
u.s. embassy compound in the heavily
fortified Green Zone compare that to the
hundreds of Iraqis who have been killed
in anti-government protests when trying
to breach the same fortified zone during
months of recent unrest president Trump
tweeted Iran will be held responsible
for the attack on the embassy but Iran's
supreme leader taunted back in a tweet
saying you can't do anything but what
America is doing is reinforcing its
troops in the region with
hundreds of soldiers from the 82nd
airborne on their way to neighboring
Kuwait joining us Marines already
bolstering security at the Embassy
that's not stopping a growing number of
Iraqi politicians calling for American
forces to be forced out of Iraq which
raises the question can diplomats repair
relations or is this the beginning of
the end of the United States military
presence in Iraq this morning Apache
helicopters are still patrolling the
skies over the embassy just underscoring
how tense it is in Baghdad
Jericka en Lee force in Baghdad thank
you
you